hi today I wanted to talk about
something which I consider extremely
important not all in one language
learning but also in our lives in
general today is our capacity of making
mistakes and learning from them now I
like the saying in general that no one
on this planet has never made a mistake
everybody has made a one two three
countless mistakes in their lives and
this is not only this not only goes for
human beings but this is also happens
also happens in the animal world
for example monkeys according to sort of
scientific research monkeys actually
learn by observing their peers that's
enough the difference between us and
monkeys is that we hunger our mistakes
we have the capacity of thinking about
what we did wrong now let me tell you
what I think is the main problem here
with making mistakes we all went to
school to learn something now in the
school system especially if we consider
a language learning we have all been
braided on our language skills because
teachers need to evaluate us sometimes
this is done in some sort of in a way a
store remember for example anytime in my
school I need got a little bit
discouraged when I got that marked I
believe that this has a negative impact
this had a negative impact on my
willingness to improve my language
skills and I believe that that happened
to some of you as well now I believe
that if we develop a different way of
dealing with mistakes
it can change everyday now let me show
you for example when we when we start
being independent learners so when we
finish high school would still keep the
burden of being judged it's a way
whether it is unconscious or conscious
so I heard and I said I've seen
countless times once such as perfectly
made
accent perfect accent perfect grammar
you speak the language perfectly this
choice of words indicates suggests that
I believe a lot of people see language
learning as a performance principle he
speaks better than you I speak better
than hearing etc etc and I believe this
kind of attitude is not only useless but
it could be dangerous it could hamper us
from a learning language on our home and
I'm learning it effectively I believe
the language learning is not a
competition it's not a performance it's
about communicating with others and I
also believe that nobody is perfect and
even if we pray for perfection we want
to reach the sky but we'll never reach
it it really doesn't matter for example
in this in this system we tend to see
native speakers as role models and
sometimes we tend to forget the native
speakers make quite a few mistakes for
themselves the fact that there are
native speakers doesn't necessarily mean
that they don't make mistakes or they
have never they a mistake they make
quite a few mistakes as well I remember
I'm an Italian a native Italian speaker
and I remember that in order to speak
Italian fluently and well and being able
to write correctly I spent quite a lot
of time trying to you know to learn as
much as I could I do remember that when
I was 10 my writing skills were not
we're not very good so it's desperately
trying to find a way to improve them and
I remember that I started reading a book
actually a lot of books and that kind of
changed things but I also developed a
sound positive attitudes attitude
towards being corrected so in general I
believe that language learning actually
is not only about expansion that is
learning more words and learning more
structures and more sentences for verbs
etc etc but it's also about requirement
it means that we not only expand our
knowledge by input by listening by
reading they getting exposure to getting
exposed being exposed to to the language
but also to we refine the line
itself we refine our skills by human
interaction by producing something by
riding but by also by talking to others
and if we develop a sound attitude
towards towards it we can improve our
language skills dramatically this is
what I would I believe now let me give
you a few guidelines first I would like
to say that when people talk about the
feedback and the fact that being
corrected is not very useful I would
like to stress the fact that it really
depends on how you deliver the feedback
and how you receive it if the very first
you know I'm gonna I'm going to show you
four main guidelines I believe they're
very important points the very first
thing that I would do to refine my
language skills and expand them
obviously is to find a good language
partner now when I talk about delivering
the feedback in the wrong way imagine
being in a bar and you just give the
learning of let's say Spanish for a
couple of months and you stumble upon a
very negative person correct you have
three seconds obviously you're not very
happy about it because it disrupts the
flow of your speech and hamper see it
keeps you from speaking and to motivates
you and discourages you and I believe
that there are not a lot of people like
that but they do exist and if you're
especially at the beginning is the
beginning phase if you stumble upon
these people they can actually destroy
your will to learn but at the same time
I still believe that in this world and
especially when you're looking for a
language partner you can find a lot of
like-minded people actually helped you a
lot and they think like you they can
actually identify with you and they
understand that as a language learner
you want to learn so you're willing to
make mistakes and being corrected and
improve your skills but I would like to
emphasize the fact that you have to
first find the giving each partner now
you can find an email
you're sitting if you live in a big city
in our national CA that'd be great but
if even if you don't you can always use
Skype the website comes to what comes to
mind share talk for example WWC org
where you can find a lot of people
willing to talk to you but there are a
lot of sites like that and then you have
to find a nice person and as I said
before by nice person I mean a
like-minded person like you and you if
this is kind of a sort of trial and
error process so you first talk to a
person you see if they if you like them
for example then you can tell them ok
let's exchange Skype and let's start
talking this is quite important the
second point is to expand and refine
when you have a language partner all you
have to do is to talk to them in the
target language and as I said before
expanding means that even if you don't
know the language very well and this is
what I've been doing especially in
Polish recently with my dear friend Nico
even if you don't know a lot of words
you know I don't believe when I hear
people say well if you don't have words
you cannot speak that's true if you're
talking yourself but if you're talking
to another person you can always ask you
but can you please tell me how to say
this and they can deliver this
information in in a second so you can
keep talking
and this goes faster and faster and but
then you also have to refine your
language skills one of the best ways to
do that is that when we talk when we
engage in a conversation especially if
we don't know the language quite well
okay our brain has to grapple has to
cope with a lot of things the syntax
pronunciation the words intonation
meanie etc etc so we kind of struggle at
the beginning because we have to our
brain has to come from a lot of things
but if you record the conversation then
you will be able to listen to yourself
and to be more relaxed and to learn from
your own mistakes when that person
corrects them and you can tell them
please correctly but do it later I will
try to say some things at the end of my
might speech or what you're trying to
say you can't correct
so you will have all the from that all
the corrections there and you will be
able to listen to yourself trying to
speak this is the refinement process the
third of the third advice sorry that I
would like to give you is that and try
to choose subjects you really want to
talk about the language learning is
communication let your language skills
will be driven by the desire of getting
your point across when you're talking
about things you really like if you like
talking about biology's you like talking
about any single subject I've been
teaching I've been coaching and training
more than seven people in the last two
years in a lot of languages and the
first thing that I do and important this
you know for a lot of students is today
we're going to talk about something you
really like and when they really want to
talk about something they feel this
desire and they don't really care about
being corrected so they they they talk
for a bit I correct liver the
corrections and then they keep talking
because they want to tell me what
happened especially or not just talking
about biology or any subjects but also
personal experience because we learn
also learn languages by wanting to
communicate with others and this is an
extremely important point the third of
the third one is that you have to be
curious and you have to keep the
positive attitude towards being
corrected as I said before obviously
it's important that when you talked
about feedback it's important to be
corrected in a constructive way but we
also have to accept the correction in
the constructive way and I would like to
say that making mistakes can be also can
also be fun you have to be you have to
be that serious about it because with
only mistake so to remember an episode
which is quite funny my Italian friend
here in Paris she when she first arrived
here she couldn't speak French very well
well she could speak French where well
but she still didn't understand Moo as
an employee so she was dating a guy and
this guy at the end of the shoe she was
at the end of the of the night she told
him she has to made sugar bum busy a
which in French means don't you wanna
you know have sex with me don't you
wanna yeah word e and he is the thing is
that she made a mistake because in
Italian but shot it which kind of
corresponds to busy means to kiss so she
thought she had asked him do you want to
don't you want to kiss me but he she
actually understood you know the don't
you wanna cook me so and then they
laughed together with a smile together
and she will always remember that
mistake so mistakes are not necessarily
a bad thing actually I would like to
emphasize the fact of mistakes and if
you know how to deal with mistakes they
can really change your life I would like
to conclude by quoting mr. Einstein a
man whom I really admire and he said and
legacy here pretty anyone who has never
made a mistake has never tried anything
you thank you for listening bye